[Music]
[Applause]
uh jared goff the lions quarterback uh
let me see i got the numbers here last
year he threw for almost 4 000 yards 20
touchdowns 13 interceptions
and uh of course was the quarterback
when the rams went to the super bowl
and uh jared goff joining us on the
program what um how long did it take for
you to feel comfortable looking at
yourself in a lion's uniform
uh you know it wasn't it wasn't too long
pretty quickly i think you know seeing
that jersey for the first time is you
know maybe a little a little different
but uh you know it's it's been fun man
it's been a good transition and yeah so
maybe a week
and uh what was your first impression of
coach campbell
man when i first met him i mean when i
first talked to him on the phone um you
know it was it was obviously exciting
and um to hear from him and to hear his
voice and and to hear how excited he was
about me and and just furthermore
getting the chance to talk to him was
was fun it was really cool and and
really really gave me that you know the
rejuvenation that breath of fresh air
thing and
then being around him ever since then
it's it's more the same you know the
dude's genuine he is who he is and um
i'm excited to see him and and be a part
of this you know whole turnaround here
but what's how's his coaching style play
into what you need to do to be
successful
me personally
yeah
yeah uh you know i think he has a nice
mix of
you know telling you the truth when it's
not what you want to hear and at the
same time you know he's he's a loving
guy he's a loving coach
and gives you that as well so it's a
good mix of that and and for me
personally i love it you know i love
being held accountable with what i need
to do and at the same time you know just
if i do something right let me know
how would you do arm wrestling with him
he'd kick my ass
he looks like he can still play he looks
like he can still play and uh you know
we joke with him all the time hey man
you got a few reps in you and he says no
of course not but you know maybe one of
these days we're going to run a couple
routes but you can't be hurt around him
can you like you can't say i'm banged up
because it
he tells all these stories where he
played through a lot of pain
yeah no doubt i mean it is it is fun to
play for a guy who's kind of been
through it truly firsthand experience on
multiple teams on multiple good teams
and on teams that haven't had success
he's seen both sides of it and he's
obviously had his trials and
tribulations as a player and like you
mentioned you know he's he's been banged
up i'm sure the tight end position
playing the way he did so yeah there
isn't much uh much to complain about
around him that's for sure explain this
to uh our audience and those of us who
never played when a coach said all was a
bad practice like what is a bad practice
in august
yeah usually i mean at least now it's
you know it's sloppy it's hot it's you
know you know guys are jumping offsides
balls are getting dropped or missing
throws
it's
more so mental than anything at this
point you know when guys get tired you
know some of those mental mistakes come
up and i think that's the sign of a good
team is is when you know it is hot and
you are tired and things aren't going
your way to stay on point and do what
you're supposed to do
what's the worst thing a rookie can do
show plate
oh or or not do what the veterans tell
them to do what happens if they show up
late
i mean it's a it's a fine it's it's
whatever the coach decides to do but
it's it's more so just kind of a you
know showing that you're not really a
pro yet you know and for them we haven't
had any of that which has been good but
i think furthermore you know if that
asks you to go pick them up some food
you go pick them up some food or
something like that did you get hazed
with the rams
uh you know when i was there fischer was
the head coach as a rookie and and he
was pretty you know just firmly against
that so i didn't have much of it i
remember i had to i had to run coffee
runs for for case and sean mannion at
the time and that was that was that was
part of the job at that time and case
couldn't have been couldn't have been
better to me as a rookie so it was good
with it but also when you get to that
point where they know that you're going
to be the starting quarterback but in
the meantime you kind of have to do what
they tell you to do you got to pay your
dues man everyone does no matter no
matter who you are and i think that's
kind of consistent across the league and
it was no different for me that's for
sure what are the expectations in
detroit
and how did they change from what they
were with the rams
yeah i mean internally they don't change
internally it's you know win games and
and first goal is win your division and
then go from there and be in the
playoffs internally obviously the
external uh
uh
you know
implications are different and what
people think of the team may be
different but internally uh it's the
same every year for all 32 teams i would
imagine and we're no different you know
we've got all the players we can have we
could ever want and all the coaches we
could ever want we got everything here
it's about going out and executing doing
your job and showing up on sundays
what's the biggest difference between la
and
detroit oh man i mean
the culture is entirely different uh i'm
speaking about the city um
you know uh just being around the city
it's it's different it's the midwest you
know it's
it's
it's more there's more like i think
there's a little more culinary out here
which is cool for me to experience
there's obviously more you know green
more lakes which is cool um i've lived
in california my whole life so getting
to experience this has been really fun
for me and and really a cool experience
but it's a kind of a beer and shot kind
of place it's not white not white wine i
keep saying this now and everyone keeps
telling me oh just wait till the winner
and i know it's
i'm enjoying it right now and think you
know they could play inside and get some
indoor games later in the year as well
yeah you're okay minnesota you're inside
detroit you play inside i mean you got
to go to lambeau
yeah that's all right we played there in
january chicago
yep yep what's your worst weather you
ever played in
worst weather oh man um
we had one in denver that was
surprisingly cold a few years ago i
think it was about 10 degrees
it wasn't snowing it was just cold um
and then it snowed a little bit in that
green bay game last year but that wasn't
particularly cold it was just it was
just a little drizzle snow i've never
had like the white field stuff i've
never had to experience that so maybe i
will but it'll be fun
you're going to
i can't wait
we're talking to the lions quarterback
jared goff uh finish this sentence the
reason why i'm no longer a ram is
oh man dan that's not a question for me
um well why you think you're not a ram
hey man they had they had decisions to
make they wanted to make the decision
that's part of this league and the way
things go but i couldn't be happier to
be here and i've had so much fun um you
know building this thing up with dan and
the rest of the coaches and players and
it's been it's been a joy for me it's
really has been it's it's been it's been
a really fun challenge and something
that i'm looking forward to putting on
the field this fall i i know you don't
want to look back i'm just curious
curious about the process of moving
forward
how do you get over a breakup
when somebody says they no longer like
you
i i mean you it's it's the same way as
anything else you know i got people who
do like me and you focus on that you
focus on what you have and and all the
good things and and you know that it's
part of this league it's part of the
business i mean i'm sure you know it's
not quite the same but in some regards
you guys go through in the media with
you know espn or or where you're at now
like it's it's
you know you got people that do love you
and you got people that don't anymore
and that's the way things go yeah but
i'm still mad at espn see i've gone past
that yeah yeah are you still mad
yeah and you can be mad and and there's
parts of me that still are of course but
you know i've got i've got some things
to look forward to here that i'm excited
about
uh what do you do with your old rams
gear because if you don't want it maybe
i could give it to the dance for a
christmas gift yeah i'll send it to you
guys i don't know haven't do it anymore
i've probably been donated at this point
but uh yeah i'll see you guys some lions
here instead how's that sound
that's okay all right i mean i'm okay
with that but uh have you gotten
mistaken for ryan gosling in detroit
uh no i have not no
that was just an la thing
yeah and that doesn't i i mean i haven't
had that happen in quite a while but uh
you know
that would if that were to happen it
would happen much more in l.a no no and
it's a good thing that if it happens i
mean you know if somebody says oh hey i
love you uh in your movies like that's
okay
yeah it's okay that's okay yeah i'll
just i'll play along with it at times
yeah
well uh good luck there in detroit great
to talk to you again and uh we
appreciate your time
thank you dan i appreciate it it's
always fun on here and i hope you and
the danettes have a have a solid weekend
i got
i got the uh the old rams jersey here
the jared goff jersey um
well it's time for a new one huh
how about after your first win could i
uh can we get the lions first win and we
hang that up
i can give you one that looks like it
[Laughter]
wait are you gonna use that for some
wait you're gonna keep that for yourself
that one yeah
okay how about the third win
sure you can have the third one
third third mcleven would you check when
when golf is playing who's he playing
like the third game when's he playing
rogers or somebody can we find this out
we need like i need you to beat somebody
substantial here
we played green by a week two
oh so i can't get that jersey yeah
paulie you got ooh yeah that's early uh
bears week four vikings week five oh
okay conference i like it i like it oh
they just they host the bengals sorry
you wait are you calling your victory
here no i'm saying i'm saying
which one would you like
how about rams week seven
okay
[Laughter]
i didn't want to bring that up paulie
made me bring that up that's all right
yeah hey thanks for joining us good luck
hey i appreciate it man thanks for
having me
so jared goff
yeah we'll take the lions jersey when
you play the rams